donc il y à une opposition farouche
contre ces center parcs vous répondez
quoi c'est un vrai sujet de débat moi
j'ai posé des conditions
les conditions écologiques et des
conditions financières une faisabilité
financière qui aujourd'hui n'est pas au
rendez vous et effectivement des
conditions écologiques par rapport à la
préservation de la ressource en eau mais
aujourd'hui on en est même pas à l'étude
de ces conditions là parce qu'on est sur
des questions de paix et lui et de
réglementations qui font qu'aujourd'hui
les deux en local et deux initiés sont
complètement enlisé et on n'est pas
encore en situation de me répondre sur
les conditions que j'ai mise mais moi je
me disais vous venez de celle moi je ne
soutiendrai pas un projet de center
parcs qui par ailleurs peut être
intéressant pour le développement
économique et la création d'emploi local
si les conditions que j'ai mise au
niveau écologique et au niveau de
l'ingénierie financière ne sont pas
résolues rapatrient leurs marques en
bourgogne franche comté pas tout de
suite
alors vous parlez